première fois depuis le début de
l'invasion russe que le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan foulent le sol
ukrainien celui qui s'est rendu
plusieurs fois à moscou de jouer les
médiateurs avec plats dits nikitine et
qui refuse toujours de sanctionner la
russie a tenu à clarifier la position de
la turquie ce jeudi
tout en poursuivant nos efforts pour
trouver une solution au conflit
nous avons été et continueront à être du
côté de nos amis green
[Musique]
autres invités de premier plan le
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres s ensemble les trois hommes ont
mis sur la table plusieurs sujets
brûlants à commencer par le risque d'une
catastrophe nucléaire à la centrale de
zappos ridja sous contrôle russe depuis
mars dernier les bombardements répétés
autour des réacteurs nucléaires font
craindre le pire à la communauté
internationale
l'équipement et le personnel militaire
doivent être retirés de la centrale tout
nouveau déploiement de forces ou
d'équipement sur le site doit être évité
la zone doit être démilitarisé nous
devons dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont tous dégâts potentiels à zaporijia
serait un suicide
il a aussi été question d' intensifier
les exportations de céréales or
d'ukraine avant l'hiver objectif éviter
une crise alimentaire mondiale notamment
sur le continent africain fortement
dépendants du blé ukrainien
et il restera le garant de la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale
l'accord signé fin juillet entre kiev et
moscou a permis à deux premiers cargos
remplis de blé de quitter les ports
ukrainiens mais sur la question de la
paix volodymyr celle un style reste
inflexible il l'a répété ce jeudi il n'y
aura pas de négociations de paix sans le
retrait préalable des troupes russes du
territoire ukrainien
nous restons en uc